and staying in china the country has
recorded its fourth rise in new
coronavirus cases in a row that's
despite some 13 million people already
under lockdown in the country's shanxi
province the spike in cases there has
produced china's highest infection rates
since the pandemic's very first outbreak
in wuhan
it's been almost two years since china
has seen the streets of major cities
deserted
but once again millions are back under
lockdown
authorities widened the restrictions
across shanxi province on tuesday
as they grapple with the country's
biggest outbreak since the initial
months of the pandemic
china has pursued a zero tolerance
approach
rolling out mass testing and draconian
lockdowns for relatively small outbreaks
in shanxi's capital city of sian 13
million residents are under strict
stay-at-home orders after reporting less
than 200 daily infections
we have quickly adopted containment
measures for these risk areas
the implementation of various measures
will help to effectively control the
outbreak
despite administering almost three
billion jabs initial research shows the
locally produced synovac offers limited
protection against the omicron variant
the beijing winter olympics are set to
start in just over a month
with only spectators from mainland china
permitted to attend
with diplomatic boycotts already being
announced
beijing will be eager to ensure that
covert outbreaks don't further chill the
already frosty atmosphere
for more let's bring in correspondent
fabian kreshner in beijing fabian the
numbers are bear repeating 13 million
people in lockdown for less than 200
daily infections how are chinese
citizens coping with such tough measures
well i mean the general um
public are supporting those measures
mostly and the reason is that in most
parts of china right now you can live a
relatively carefree um normal life
without
restrictions however the people who are
affected by the zero covert strategy
namely the citizens of xi'an who are
really under a strict lockdown they
cannot even leave their house right now
they are relying on
neighborhood committees to send them
food and daily necessities they are
making a lot of sacrifices and if you
scroll through um social media for
example weibo which is the dominant um
online platform here you can find signs
of discontent for example people
complaining that they're running out of
daily necessities and that there are no
new supplies however
most of the posts have since been
deleted and it's not really easy to have
an open and critical debate about the
virus strategy because it is sensitive
in china to criticize the government
no doubt as we uh just heard in the
report the chinese vaccine sinovac
appears to offer limited protection
against the amucon variant i'm curious
is the country looking into other
vaccines as an option for booster shots
i don't see that happening the reasons
why for example bayern tech moderna they
have not been approved in china that
there was a purely political decision um
the state media here and also the
government they've placed their own
domestic vaccines as being superior and
now it would be a huge lodge a loss of
face if they would turn to a foreign and
especially western vaccines what they
are betting on is that cyberware sino
farm their own vaccine producers are
developing a new generation of mrna
vaccines and then they get approved but
the bigger picture is or the bigger
question that people are wondering is
what is the long-term goal what is the
exit strategy i mean so far it's hard to
imagine that china will
open up its borders anytime soon
fabian one imagines china needs to show
they've got the virus under control
ahead of the olympics just very briefly
if you can what's at stake
well the national prestige last year
they claimed the victory over the virus
and
now the situation is quite different but
the
olympics themselves they will be under a
strict bubble and the games are not um
yeah at danger i think they will take
place mostly without spectators but um
yeah there will be a very strict covet
bubble during the games uh to seal off
um yeah the athletes and the journalists
from the rest of the population that's
fabian kreshmar in beijing many thanks
favian
now to some other developments in the
global pandemic france has announced a
record number of new coronavirus
infections authorities counted almost
180 000 new cases in 24 hours new cases
are soaring in australia as well health
officials in new south wales warn that
the sudden outbreak is overwhelming
testing centers causing long queues and
delays in receiving test results and the
who has warned that the omicron variant
still poses a very high risk and could
overwhelm health systems
you